[Musique]
au coeur de la forêt amazonienne le
marrane yonne
1700 km l'un des plus longs fleuves du
pérou
sur ses rives des milliers d'habitants
vivent loin de tout accès médicale deux
fois par an le selva viva remonte le
fleuve de village en village pour
apporter soins et médicaments
alors on va faire le tour du bateau
juliana coordonne un voyage humanitaire
pour la première fois de sa vie ici vous
avez la salle de bain cette jeune
française de 28 ans travaille pour une
ong franco péruvienne elle accueille
l'équipe médicale un médecin et une
infirmière
ont bas il ya les chambres et aux
premières et el fassi la terrasse
dans les clips il y également une
sage-femme et des dentistes des
bénévoles péruvien ils vont tous passer
dix jours à bord
en france avec un diplôme en sociologie
juliana ne trouvait pas de travail
la patience pas maîtrise de soi
la zen attitude
être professionnel
pouvoir anticiper davantage
de l'expérience quoi avec tout ce qui
lui reste à faire difficile de rester
zen le bateau est amarré à iquitos la
capitale de l'amazonie péruvienne
juliana a quitté le pays basque pour s'y
installer il y a deux mois à peine
je vais tourner au niveau de la place
dernier fait partie il faut un paquet
tous les médicaments tous les achats de
dernière minute
la
française
oui
elle prépare ce voyage avec la brigade
médicale du fleuve depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est aussi l'occasion pour
elle de découvrir en profondeur la
masoni un petit peu moins pour le show
pour la pluie mais aussi des habits qui
couvre tout le corps parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de moustiques c'est la première
vraie y être je vais accompagner donc je
suis tout excité qui peut stresser au 6
mai
mais je pense que ça va bien se passer
voilà on l'appelle
avant de partir il lui reste une étape
essentielle l'hôpital de la région elle
valait en charge
tu peux venir nous donner un coup de
main
la jeune femme a réussi à convaincre
l'établissement de lui faire un don de
1000 euros un médicament
merci beaucoup
un don qui va permettre à son équipe de
soigner plus de 1000 personnes pendant
dix jours
un autre français est aussi du voyage
philippe 47 ans est chargé de la
logistique
à quelques heures du départ il fait son
marché pour nourrir tous les passagers
du bateau pendant leur mission ça c'est
du mara ce kit animal de la forêt du
gibier du genre un rongeur
aïe ça y'a bien 6 kg oui ces kilos
philippe est arrivée au pérou il ya un
an depuis il a sillonné l'amazone une
dizaine de fois amazon prend naissance
un peu plus au nord à quelques
kilomètres d'ici à noter le mariole
pendant une journée complète on va
arriver sur la zone où on va penser du
soir
après une séparation douloureuse ce père
de quatre enfants a tout quitté pour
l'amazonie
aujourd'hui philippe vi sur le bateau à
l'année
voilà vous êtes dans ma tanière
c'est mon boulot d'un côté le les autres
j'habite sur le bateau donc c'est ma
maison
loin de sa franche comté il a appris à
connaître les traditions locales chasse
à des petites choses mais j'ai trouvé
dans les différentes communautés qu'on
visite ici ça porte bonheur il y en a
certains qui met ça dans le berceau des
enfants à la naissance pour randonner de
la chance
le bateau va remonter le fleuve et
s'enfoncer au coeur de l'une des régions
les plus pauvres du perron
amis kilomètres de là au sud du pérou
antoine 48 ans s'est installé ici il ya
18 ans il est marié avec une péruvienne
je voyage en toute l'amérique du sud
mais finalement je reste avec le père ou
quoi nous paierons c'est le plus beau
pays d'amérique ce pays antoine le fait
découvrir aux touristes à sa façon il a
créé une agence de voyages qui organise
des treks personnalisés
bonjour comment ça va
salut moi c'est antoine jacques je vous
reconnais ont sévi sur sky va donc c'est
bien vous êtes prêts on était bon ben on
est parti alors un lego
pendant deux semaines antoine homé jack
et laura visiter les sites incas et
rencontrer les communautés andines
là on a à peu près trois quarts d'heure
de route au début ça sera le thé après
c'est une piste en terre
on va arriver à la communauté de pata
bamba et donc on va partir pour
disons trois heures de marche des
questions pas pour le moment c'est vrai
que
ça fait longtemps que j'en attends c'est
un congrès c'est trop bien super
on a choisi antoine pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il propose
un voyage un peu à la carte et en dehors
des sentiments voilà on va marcher
visitez les sites des heures un petit
peu en décalage par rapport aux flux de
touristes contre les rencontrer les gens
dormir chez l'habitant et donc c'est
vraiment ça que c'est ça qu'on voulait
quoi
les bagages vont maintenant les suivre à
dos de mule c'est bon vous êtes prêt à
l'ailé ce beau
mais perso je ne reçois plus loin
eux vont continuer à pied une randonnée
unique dans la cordillère des andes
voilà on va prendre le chemin qui est là
en face d un non on va descendre sur ce
chemin mais ensuite on va prendre un
sentier en balcon au-dessus le rsa créé
la vallée sacrée un chemin mythique qui
regorge de vestiges incas une
civilisation née au début du xiiie
siècle
aujourd'hui disparu
une porte double comme ça ça montre que
on accède à 1,7 soit religieux soit du
pouvoir politique un cas
les sommets antoine koné il a passé son
enfance dans les alpes
j'aime bien jusqu à partir de 4000
danser steppe rase il fait plus frais
déjà et un petit vent frais qui fait du
bien quand on marche et puis je ne sais
pas ça me booste en fait si on m'a
empêché de monter à 4 milles pendant des
années je crois que je déprime ray
ça c'est mes gags praticiens non plus de
nature salle au monde wade dont on vient
les escaliers là qu'on est rendus là en
face tu vois est tout à fait on va
s'asseoir ici
pour les aider à supporter l'altitude
antoine les initier à la tradition de la
coca
la coca c'est le lien entre les hommes
et les esprits des montagnes des habous
et il souffle dessus pour envoyer leurs
prières leurs remerciements d'environ 3
comme ça et puis
[Musique]
même si j'apprécie pas juste hâtivement
ne serait ce que pour le cadre
l'expérience excellent quoi
donc je prends quand même du plaisir
me la jouer péruvien
quand tu vis pendant des années dans un
pays forcément tu en adopte beaucoup de
coutume
après quand on accueille des gens qui
viennent et qui sont intéressés par la
culture de ce pays on essaye de leur
transmettre tout ce que tu as tout ce
qui tout ce que tu as appris et tout ce
que tu vas le risque dans la culture de
ce pays
alors ici on est sur le site de mora y
chaque terrasse à une paix ratures
différentes et selon l'exposition et la
profondeur les incas pouvez étudier les
comportements des plantes pour savoir
quel endroit ces plantes allait donner
une meilleure production il a en fait
l'ombre il enlève l'herbe
antoine s'est pris de passion pour les
incas pendant un cours d'histoire
à 9 ans j'ai écouté ses mots un cas
titicaca cuzco et machu picchu j'ai eu
le rêve devenir de voir tout ça de mes
propres yeux de le comprendre et j'ai
tout fait pour venir ici vraiment ça m'a
mis des années et maintenant que je suis
ici tous les jours depuis depuis 18 ans
je réalise un rêve
voilà
après une nuit de navigation
le bateau arrive enfin au premier
village
là a priori on va s'installer dans
l'église d'après ce que nous a dit le
capital donc on va voir ce que ça donne
là on découvre
ils vont passer deux jours dans ce
village de 260 habitants
bonjour bonjour comment allez va
dans la petite église ils sont
accueillis par un serment nous voulons
remercier mon dieu car tu es grand nous
croyons que tu as amené ici la main et
le coeur de ces personnes pour qui nous
libère de nos douleurs
merci seigneur m'a même
merci beaucoup on va commencer les
consultations
l'éditeur et la salle d'attenté déjà
bien remplie
la présence de médecins est si rare que
c'est par familles entières que les
habitants se sont déplacés
tous vos enfants sont là juliana est
chargée d'enregistrer les patients
qu'est ce que tu as à l'ats daniela elle
en a sur tout le corps
ah mais ce sont des parasites oui c'est
la grâce
il faut que tu lui donnes un bain avec
du pamplemousse et du citron ça va les
faire sortir
la petite daniela a aussi du mal à
respirer et à beaucoup de fièvre
aujourd'hui des cas comme celui là le
médecin on verra une vingtaine
le centre de santé à quelques heures
d'ici qu'ils ont pas accès à des soins
médicaux ils ont absolument pas accès à
des soins dentaires donc ça permet
d'apporter
des services de santé basiques en fait
dans leur communauté et c'est gratuit
ici c'est la tête et là ce sont ces
petits
juste à côté la sage femme enchaîne les
consultations
sais tu sens la tête de ton bébé
cette future maman enceinte de sept mois
n'a jamais eu de contrôle pour vérifier
que le bébé va bien la sage femme n'a
qu'un instrument rudimentaire qui permet
d'écouter son coeur
si je n'ai pas le choix je dois me
débrouiller avec les moyens du bord
sur le bateau philippe transforme le
pont du navire en cabinet dentaire
c'est la première fois que les
villageois vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce
genre de soins un dentiste à prêter du
matériel
notre approche de ce qu'on connaît en
europe ces modèles model de campagne
une demi-heure plus tard hermine dallas
dentiste reçoit son premier patient
c'est à la caf assieds toi là tu vas tu
allongée et je vais m'occuper de toi
tout de suite d'accord
on
s'aperçut tu regardes il n'y a pas d'eau
qui sort
wen
l'eau doit sortir d'ici
mais ya pas de tuyau
si cela c'est le tuyau d'arrivée d'eau
pour que la machine fonctionne philippe
est obligé de tenir le tuyau
ouais c'est tout une solution d'ici
demain pour améliorer la situation parce
que là ça devient fastidieux poubelles
journée appuyer sa
aucune personne pour pas grand chose
voilà ton ballon
c'est pourtant courage et
toute la journée une quarantaine de
patients se succèdent
à ces
noms paillasse et ce siège là le vôtre
c'est plus pratique pour moi
je vous remercie beaucoup d'être venu
jusqu'ici pour nous montrer qu'on peut
soigner des dons c'est la première fois
qu'on te soigne les dents oui avant on
les arrache et
hermine da philippe et ses collègues
travaillerons jusqu'à la tombée de la
nuit
[Musique]
après avoir passé deux jours dans ce
village le bateau continue à s'enfoncer
un peu plus dans la jungle
dans cette région son téléphone et
internet philippe a trouvé sa place
le contact avec les gens ici me plaît le
fait de naviguer de livres sous l'eau
parce que le lever de soleil sont
fabuleux c'est très apaisant c'est très
reposant
mais le bateau doit accoster en urgence
comme pour faire exprès il a plu et de
la partie
philippe doit déménager tout
l'équipement médical dans un bateau
annexes
on est obligé d'emprunter le bateau
auxiliaires parce qu'on peut pas rentrer
avec avec le grand bateau là on peut
voir tirs des branchages partout au
milieu du passage
il faut tout réinstaller
déjà une vingtaine de familles fait la
queue devant le dispensaire improvisé
ne vous inquiétez pas vous allez passer
en consultation avec le médecin puis
avec les dentistes mais s'il vous plaît
madame prenez vos enfants est restée
assise
arrivée 11 heures il ya un monde fou
dehors je ne sais pas quoi faire je
continue à les enregistrer ou pas
oui tu les enregistrais tu leur dis de
revenir cet après midi
la jeune femme n'a pas l'expérience de
philippe
elle a du mal à rester zen
c'est vivre en sabots
[Musique]
c'est sale et bien moi on va pas du tout
barbare tout on à la journée
donc je sais pas trop
les enfants s'il vous plaît au milieu de
l'agitation et des cris d'enfants une
urgence mobilise l'équipe médicale à
deux ans le petit christian ne pèse que
5 kg il est en danger de mort
comment s'appelle thomas rey 1 andres
il est venu avec toi
[Musique]
il n'y a pas un membre de la famille qui
peut venir nous aider à deux ans ce
petit garçon est en danger de mort
il faudrait trouver du lait en poudre
enrichi et non
oui ce serait bien parce qu'il tient à
peine debout il a deux ans et il fait le
poids d'un enfant de six huit mois
et on peut trouver du lait enrichi sinon
rien à part pour trouver du lait enrichi
il faut se rendre en ville pour la maman
c'est trop loin et trop cher
ses propos certains chantent une
collecte quoi pour essayer d'aider la
maman
philippe et l'équipe vont tout faire
pour l'évacuer d'urgence mais il faut
aussi s'occuper des autres habitants
en attendant l'enfant repart avec sa
mère
sur le bateau après 10 heures de
consultation l'équipe a découvert que le
petit christian est né hors mariage et
que son beau-père refusent de le nourrir
de toutes les brigades que j'ai fait je
n'ai jamais vu ça c'est inacceptable
c'est criminel
il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose on
peut pas laisser les choses en l'état il
ya vraiment un cas là de une
la pierre chevènement
il décide d'évacuer le petit garçon dès
l'aube
le lendemain
juliana aimerait que les autorités du
village force le boupère envoyé l'enfant
à l'hôpital
c'est diplomatique on va dire pour
éviter aussi que notre action soit mal
perçu
parce que si on veut continuer à
réaliser des brigades et puis à venir
apporter un
des soins comme un fait là il faut qu'on
garde des bonnes relations
juliana propose aux chefs de village que
l'association paie le transport de toute
la famille vers l'hôpital de n'a autant
après une heure de pourparlers les
parents acceptent
bonjour rien bonjour philippe accompagne
l'infirmière qui va prendre le bateau
avec la famille jusqu'à l'hôpital
le beau-père ne dit pas un mot
j'avais le sentiment de mission
accomplie la non pas vraiment parce que
là on a fait on a fait l'urgence on a
assuré la logistique qui est qui et plus
le plus gros problème ici c'est les
transports c'est les distances et
maintenant
elles viennent que pour
quatre jours plus tard le couple
retirera l'enfant de l'hôpital sans
explication depuis l'équipe n'a aucune
nouvelle
aussi au lieu au jour le jour je vous
apporte la surprise en même temps il
faut être préparé à tout tout peut
arriver
quatre autres communautés attendre la
visite de l'équipe avec impatience
antoine et le jeune couple eux ont déjà
marché quatre jours à travers les
montagnes andines
ils ont fait étape à chint chéreau un
village un cas entièrement restauré
traverser les salines de maras 4000
bassin de sel accroché à la montagne
créée par les incas est toujours
exploité par les paysans de la région
cette forteresse fut le siège de combats
acharnés lors de la conquête espagnole
au xvième siècle
et on voit que les pierres sont
parfaitement taillés et la porte
impressionnant
chaque soir pas d'hôtels 5 étoiles mais
des étapes chez les amis d'antoine au
mode de vie ancestral
ce soir il les emmène chez un couple de
paysans qui vit dans les montagnes
bonsoir madame comment vas tu
silverio c'est sympa de voir
antoine l'état rencontré il ya six ans
lors d'une balade dans les montagnes
dès qu'il fait visiter le perron c'est
chez eux qu'ils passent la nuit
vous avez marché comme des tortues oui
comme des grosses dents
jacques et laura vont dormir dans cette
petite chambre au confort plutôt modeste
fait pas trop froid s'est souvent fait
pour la mission d'al sadd sud il peut
faire froid
mais là ça va c'est nickel c'est trop
beau ces petits toits en paille c'est
typique c'est l'hyper typiquement un
petit casse-croûte traditionnelles
d'accueil on appelle ça choque le
caisson
du maïs avec du fromage un repas
traditionnel dans les andes on vient un
petit moment de leur vie et voilà c'est
ça qui est génial quoi et c'est ça qu'on
rapportera quand on rentrera en france
quoi donc c'est super c'est un souvenir
aussi
pour mama nattier son mari les visiteurs
d'antoine sont une source de revenus
providentiel
ici on peut montrer aux touristes
comment nous vivons comment nous
chantons et meudon son ça nous permet de
gagner de l'argent pour financer
l'éducation de nos enfants
après l'entrée voilà le plat de
résistance
un cochon d'inde
normand jeunes et cochons d'inde pour
les anniversaires et les faits
sont bien là le truc qui bouge elle lui
fait des nues cas
pas le déranger plus longtemps il paraît
que c'est hyper bon donc j'aimerais bien
goûter avant de partir ce ne sera pas
pour ce soir
à tuer les dindes les montres et les
cartouches rouge
la cartouche la cartouche c'est au tour
des français de montrer leurs traditions
virtuel
wim apprennent plein de choses que moi
j'ai pas que je connais pas que je sais
pas et puis et puis voilà ben moi je
suis j'ai une autre culture qui intègre
un peu ce genre de choses est bon voilà
on partage tout quoi voilà et tu la
dinde là
le lendemain matin départ en musique
c'est un petit souvenir d'un notamment
c'est trop mignon
c'est un poil de l'ama
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
allez une petite faute au shopi ouakrat
score
[Rires]
[Musique]
après plusieurs jours de marche hors des
sentiers battus antoine jacquet laura
rejoignent les grands circuits
touristiques pour visiter le site
incontournable du perron
les amis
ou quoi et voilà on arrive à machu
picchu
c'est le plus beau si c'est le plus
majestueux site le plus impressionnant
le plus grand le mieux construit de tous
les sites incas et en plus de ça il est
dans un environnement qui est
exceptionnel perchée à 2500 mètres
d'altitude
machu picchu est une cité inca
construite aux 15ème siècle
huit cent mille personnes défilent tu
ici chaque année c'est le site le plus
visité du perron
à ce qu'on voit ben vas y a pas de mots
quoi c'est juste c'est juste magnifique
c'est peut-être la 50e fois que je
reviens mais à chaque fois que je viens
c'est une grande émotion ce qui me plaît
beaucoup ici c'est qu'on voit que les
incas et et
des sculpteurs de montagne et comme
montagne à moi même c'est quelque chose
qui me fascine
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu le cochon d'inde
cette fois jacques et laura n'échappe à
la tradition du cochon dinde grillée
la voilà cochons d'inde combien il est
fourrée tout quoi
ben voilà j'en aurait touché 1 1 voulait
pas se laisser prendre d'autres chevaux
reste assez bon les premières techniques
c'est tu chopes là tu lui arrache
l'arrière-train
superbe
termes annuels de mai sting nous a un
peu du mal c'est comme s'il fallait
manger du chat ou de chien corbeau donc
je sais pas à quel goût ça ressemble à
quoi joue bien je voulais bien j'aime
bien les emmener dans des endroits qui
sont comme ça qui sont des endroits pas
complètement aseptisé et louer
même s'il faut quand même prendre des
précautions
sur le fleuve maranon yonne juliana
philippe et l'équipe médicale s'accorde
une pause
philippe lors a organisé une promenade
dans la jungle
près
d'une fenêtre animaux rien de l'amazone
mon père est un petit petite balade
janvier
il découvre un sanctuaire pour animaux
grâce à un guide local qui leur offrent
les trésors de l'amazonie sur un plateau
à regarder comme les jolies celle là
tabou ça
ça détend un peu ça fait plaisir quoi ça
permet de revenir un peu
dg
c'est une espèce que je n'avais jamais
vu la plus belle prise la voilà une
tarentule elle ne put pas
sinon l'attaquant italien si la toque
alors
à cacher
je lui ai dit de le faire donc je me dis
que c'est peut-être pas si dangereux que
ça allait mal à trouver
[Musique]
[Rires]
après dix jours d'expédition dans les
communautés d'amazonie les médecins les
dentistes vont retrouver leur cabinet en
ville
monsieur filet merci beaucoup
nous allemands
juliana va rester deux ans mission au
pérou le temps pour elle d' acquérir la
sérénité qu'elle est venue chercher et
que philippe lui a déjà trouvé
c'est la fin du voyage aussi pour
antoine et ses clients parisiens on a
commencé notre trek de la barre en
allant vers la droite
on a fait le tour la boucle est bouclée
c'est aussi un voyage qui était riche
d'un point de vue émotionnel aussi on a
pu faire énormément de rencontres avec
les habitants avec on a pu échanger puis
aussi avec antoine avec qui des liens
forts se sont se sont hissés au fur et à
mesure
du séjour antoine va retrouver sa vie
quotidienne au perron loin de la france
la france sa banque comme un peu parfois
j'ai des envies de reblochon
qui me démangent
il pas encore prêt à partir de toute
façon parce que c'est encore un pays qui
me donnent beaucoup d'émotion
de
sel fille géniale de vous avoir pu que
partager tout ça c'est top
[Rires]